[Musik]
in jadens Mund tut alles weh ich weiß es
ist doof aber ich muss gucken sonst kann
ich dir nicht helfen ich es kommt nichts
rein in den Mund nur noch mal die
Zungenspitze der Kleine hat Scharlach
und braucht
Antibiotika Anruf bei der benachbarten
Apotheke täglich fragt Kinderarzt Torben
Zimmermann ab wie viel noch auf Lager
ist ja tagchen ich mal wieder Zimmermann
hallo ich wollte Sicherheit Fragen ich
habe hier noch betreffend
infektobizillin stehen auf meiner
mitgeführten Liste dass sie noch so von
den 50 lit noch vier da haben oder drei
oder sowas stimmt das drei von der
kleinen von der großen aber gar nichts
mehr okay von den Apotheken hö ich noch
nicht dass es jetzt alles
unproblematisch wäre das ist eher
meistens oh muss ich gucken oh nie noch
eine Flasche haben wir bestellt
Nachlieferung läuft wir wissen nicht
wann also ich glaube das Ziel sollte ein
anderes
sein auch hier in der leibnit Apotheke
in hann fehlen wieder
Medikamente ich gucke mal eben der ist
nämlich auch nicht immer
lieferbar seit gut 40 Jahren ist
Magdalene Linz Apothekerin dass so viele
Medikamente nicht lieferbar sind hat sie
noch nie zuvor
erlebt wir wollen dass die Patienten gut
und sicher versorgt werden dass das eine
schwierige Situation ist wenn man den
Leuten eben sagen muss es tut mir ganz
leid aber ich kann es jetzt nicht
beschaffen wir informieren sie so wie
wir et das bekommen können wir versuchen
es jeden Tag aber wie sagt man so schön
wie soll man einem nackten Mann in die
Tasche greifen das ist bei uns bisher
nicht angekommen ne es ist ja wirklich
so infekomox gerade die Säfte die war ja
auch für Notdienst und so brauchen der
Zeit nicht zu bekommen infekomox als
antibiotikasaft für Kinder fehlt
insgesamt mehr als 500 Präparate stehen
auf Rot auch Augentropfen oder
lebensnotwendige
Blutdrucksenker ich kann es dann nur auf
eine nachlieferungsliste setzen das
heißt wenn der groß mal wieder Ware hat
und ich in dieser Auslosung in
Anführungszeichen mit drin bin dann habe
ich Glück dass ich mit versorgt werde
aber das ist wirklich geduldpiel und
Glücksspiel gerade und wenn man nicht
sofort
zuschlägt Moment weggeht dann ist es
wegg Abhilfe sollte ein
lieferengpassgesetz schaffen das im
Sommer verabschiedet wurde für
Kinderarzneimittel durften die
Hersteller ihre Preise einmalig
anheben so wollte
Bundesgesundheitsminister
die Produktion von kindermedikamenten
wieder attraktiver machen das Gesetz was
wir gemacht haben dieses
lieferengpassgesetz hat auch dazu
geführt dass jetzt sehr viel mehr
produziert wird also werden nicht in die
Lage kommen wie letztes Jahr bei den
fiebersäften hat das
funktioniert Firmen wie der europäische
Hersteller Zentiva haben ihre Produktion
massiv gesteigert Arbeiten im Dreis
Schichtbetrieb auf Dauer aber keine
Lösung
keine Maschine kein Mensch kann 247
funktionieren oder laufen ja uns ist die
Verantwortung die wir haben als dieer
für diesen Winter natürlich sehr bewusst
wir werden diesen Winter das durchziehen
ob wir das nächste Saison genauso machen
können ja ob wir den Wirkstoff wiederum
bekommen die fachgriffe dafür bekommen
die wir benötigen ja wissen wir nicht
können wir nicht zusichern in den
vergangenen Jahren haben mehr und mehr
Hersteller die Produktion eingestellt
inzwischen liefert senentiva allein Zitt
des Bedarf an
iboprofensaft im häsischen Heppenheim
das Lager von
infekofarm das Unternehmen ist auf
kindermedikamente spezialisiert
antibiotikasäfte für Kinder sind nach
wie vor Mangelware die Lieferungen aus
Asien werden von hier aus an
Krankenhäuser und Großhandel
weitervertrieben gekommen aber kein
Antibiotika
dabei aber nur die Tabletten nicht die
Säfte bei penicillinsäften die z viel
Kinder mit Scharlach dringend brauchen
ist infekofarm einer der letzten
Anbieter in
Deutschland immer wenn eine Lieferung
antibiotikasäfte reinkommt ist sie nach
wenigen Tagen schon wieder ausverkauft
wenn wir so ein Winter erleben werden
wie letztes Jahr dann werden wir große
Probleme wieder bekommen was was
passiert dann ja dann haben wir zu wenig
Ware
dann infektoarm profitiert zwar von der
Preiserhöhung durch das
lieferengpassgesetz will aber seine
Produktion nicht hierher verlagern auch
wegen des weiterhin stark regulierten
deutschen Marktes ob durch das Gesetz
andere Unternehmen das Planen Philip
Zöller ist skeptisch was jetzt aber
manchmal so suggeriert wird dass es
dafür sorgen wird dass die Produktion
aus Asien nach Europa zurückkommt dass
wir eine Diversität an verschiedenen
Anbietern haben werden niemals das
letzte verbliebene penizillinwerk
Europas steht in Österreich die dortige
Regierung zahlte 50 million EUR an die
Firma sandos für das Werk in Kundel ohne
die Förderung hätte sandos es wohl
geschlossen auch der deutsche
Bundesgesundheitsminister will
antibiotikahersteller mit Geld locken
wollen sie mit Krankenkassen sogenannte
Rabattverträge abschließen müssen Sie in
Zukunft auch in Europa produzieren
carlutterbach ist trotz des aktuellen
medikamentenmangels
zuversichtlich die Maßnahmen die sie
getroffen haben reichen die aus Problem
der likasse zu lösen langfristig auf
jeden Fall aber sie werden nicht im
ersten Jahr wirken wir werden ja die
Rabattverträge so machen dass man in
Europa auch produzieren muss und dass es
nicht im ersten Jahr funktionieren kann
weil erst einmal die Produktionsanlagen
auch aufgebaut werden müssen das liegt
auf der Hand ich wünschte mir das Gesetz
wäre früher gemacht worden aber da war
ich noch nicht im
Amt doch die Länder fordern mehr Tempo
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in
Berlin esind Schritte aber sie reichen
eben noch nicht aus und das sehen wir ja
jetzt dass dass sie noch nicht
ausreichen und wir schlittern jetzt
wieder auf einen Winter zu ind dem es
Engpässe gibt und ich glaube das darf
eigentlich in einem in eine indust
naation wie unserer nicht stattfinden
immerhin die Bundesregierung arbeitet an
einer pharmastrategie frontal liegt der
Entwurf vor darin geht es auch um die
Prüfung von
investitionsbezuschussungen von
Produktionsstätten zur Erinnerung
österreich hat längst bezahlt während
Deutschland noch
prüft Tierarzt Michael dikans kennt
keine Lieferengpässe ihm stehen alle
Medikamente zur Verfügung in der
Tiermedizin war es üblich Medikamente zu
nutzen die für Menschen entwickelt
wurden so z.B das gängige Antibiotikum
amoxy
Clav vor einigen Jahren ich kann nicht
genau beziffern wie lange das her ist
haben wir dieses
als amoxylav aus hmedizin auch über
unsere Zulieferer bekommen na und jetzt
haben wir so viele eigene Produkte dass
wir das auch gar nicht mehr verschreiben
dürfen Medikamente in ausreichender
Menge wie die antibiotische Salbe für
nanux entzündete Lefzen aber zu hohen
Preisen Antibiotika kosten rund zwei bis
dreimal so viel wie für Menschen
Herzmedikamente sogar bis zu Zeh mal so
viel wir fragen nach bei den tierarz
Herstellern im Bundesverband für
Tiergesundheit was ist der Unterschied
zum humanmedizinmarkt
Zitat bei Tierarzneimitteln bleiben
Faktoren wie das Gesundheitswesen und
die speziellen Vorgaben für die Kassen
zur Wahl des Produktes außen
vor die Hersteller können ihre Preise
frei gestalten Tierarzneimittel ein
attraktiver Markt so ja ja gut jetzt
richtig schön tief
luften Kinderarzt Torben zimmermann
kämpft sich der wah weiter durch die
Sprechstunde ja tagchen Zimmern hier
schon
wieder medikamentenmangel und vorerst
kein Ende bis sich neue
Produktionsstätten in Europa ansiedeln
werden noch einige infektwellen durchs
Land
rollen